[Music]
reading is there a rule that fluorescent
lighting is not allowed to function
correctly in anything related to the
horror genre
show is immediately testing my patience
by starting with a jump scare i know you
want to dip a little bit of the king's
horror into your nostalgia milk but just
know you're already on thin ice
seriously there's no stairs option in
this highly [ __ ] dangerous laboratory
area
the systemic organ is clearly trained in
cinematic tension because it waits a
full 20 seconds before attacking its
completely helpless prey who still has a
sprinkler going in november the night of
november 6th 1983 was below freezing in
indiana so i'm pretty sure the wheelers
are just resource-wasting [ __ ] we're
so screwed if it's the demogorgon not
the demogorgon man i love these kids
together if there was an emmy for best
ensemble group of children that give off
80s vibes and somehow aren't completely
annoying they would have it on lock yes
knight rider staple of the 80s and we
want to make sure that you know this is
the 80s but considering mrs wheeler just
said it was a school night and that they
could finish their campaign next weekend
then mike exclaimed that they'd been
playing for 10 hours you'd have to
assume this is a sunday which is all
well and good but knight rider aired on
fridays in 1983. man we are filling up
our 80s nostalgia bingo card real fast
because we have a full-on outbreak of
kids on bikes going on this show 1980 so
hard it reminds me of the time i
survived on a three pound bag of peanut
m ms for a week it seemed like a great
idea for a while then it became
increasingly clear i should have thrown
in some protein every once in a while
stranger slender man
how is this creature unlocking this from
the outside even if telekinesis is one
of its powers would it really know about
slide locks and how to release them
really we're gonna do the same thought
the monster was one direction but it was
actually a different direction twice in
the first eight minutes of the show
will is still holding a loaded gun but
for some reason decides to lower it and
wait for the attack instead of at least
trying to shoot this kid has been pretty
smart up until now why the sudden case
of lambda the slaughter
this theme man sometimes a song is so
perfect for a show that you wonder if it
existed first and then they built the
show around it this is one of those
times perfection who the hell are the
duffer brothers sure the cohens the
fairleys the wachowskis have paved the
way for sibling teams to be a thing but
they still also use their first names in
the credits right i guess i'll just have
to make them up then sorry abner and
basel duffer this is your own fault and
in this very moment as if a new david
was being chiseled by michelangelo the
phrase dad bod became an acceptable
thing to say about another human being
if the waking up hungover with multiple
empty beer cans on the coffee table
smoking shirtless outside and smoking
while putting deodorant on wasn't enough
to convince you this man has a pretty
serious alcohol problem and nicotine
addiction let's have him chase some
pills with a beer just to hit that point
home
[Applause]
how did this phone get hung back up
we'll let it fall after his failed 9-1-1
call so did the demogorgon come back
through and tidy up how considerate step
right up and get your tickets for the
freak show because cosmo and darby
duffer can't make sure we know it's the
80s without school bullies meet stranger
things version of tweedledum and tweedle
dumber midnight frog face or toothless
that's racist ambitious and dentist
man seriously you're gonna be so cool
now it's ridiculous you know if i had to
pick an early favorite character for
this series it's gotta be barb she's
such a good friend of nancy and just
takes no one she's her own person and
the depth the writers have given her
will pay off for years to come good
thing she's not going anywhere steve
left this note early this morning but
when would he know that nancy found it
is he stalking the girl's bathroom from
his arrival all the way until first
period i mean yeah probably but man
teenage hormones are [ __ ] up a
make-out session in the bathroom i'm
sorry i lived through the 80s if there's
one place we didn't make out it was the
bathroom a teenage girl is braving this
absolute germapalooza for some pre-class
tongue wrestling also how is no one else
using this restroom at one of the
busiest times of the school day what
kind of card game are these two playing
where sergeant random here is so
carelessly showing his hand by facing
backwards and yet hopper can save the
day by moving one card around in a hand
this guy's been staring at for the last
three minutes those garden gnomes again
well i'll tell you what i'm going to get
right on that joyce byers can't find her
son this morning
is holding a donut in your mouth the
comp version of biting an apple because
hopper giving a sarcastic response to a
missing child report is about the
assholeiest thing i can think of right
now also flo couldn't have led with this
are the garden gnomes really more
important than a missing child i know
this is the 80s and all but jesus christ
also here's an extra sin just for making
me say the word gnome again after barely
surviving that no movie nonsense and now
i'm realizing i'll probably have to send
the sequel damn it 99 out of 100 times
kid goes missing the kid is with a
parent or a relative i assume the
statistic was bullsh so i did some
research and jim's actually right less
than one percent of child abductions are
stranger dangerous things but you still
made me do the [ __ ] research show so
send you my show if they took the
precaution to seal the gloves to their
sleeves with duct tape then why wouldn't
they have taken similar measures with
their boots that's where it came from
now probably the other giant sentient
goose lathered portal in this lab area
remember finish chapter 12 and answer
12.3 why in every television show and or
movie is the teacher always yelling over
the bell the homework assignment half
the kids are already out of the
classroom and he should know when class
ends you can't stop a few seconds before
and give out the homework assignment and
this is a very involved assignment what
if someone didn't hear the 12.3 part
sorry matt it's not my fault you left
the classroom at the correct time when i
was giving instructions sorry boys
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
it came don't these three have another
class to get to i guess hanging out with
a grown adult in his office is a valid
excuse for ditching sorry to interrupt
but uh may i borrow michael lucas and
dustin why is this i'm gonna say
principal pointing out and naming each
of these boys both he sweater us
mustache and the boys themselves already
know this info wouldn't he just pop in
and say i need these three guys to come
with me have you ever heard of markwood
i have not that sounds made up to me
it's from lord of the rings the hobbit
it doesn't matter how dare you lucas
this is exactly the reason dustin has a
job waiting for him on the sims team
whenever he wants it
i i thought i wasn't allowed to see him
as long as you don't have nightmares i
don't get scared like that anymore not
even of clowns spoiler alert also pretty
sure it's mike that might want to keep
clear of clowns in the future is joyce
just now looking here based on the
flashbacks this must be a place wheels
frequently at bike like this like a
cadillac of these kids would have walked
at home a bike like this might also be
an active crime scene so maybe don't be
moving and handling the evidence until
the folks from the hit spin-off csi
hawkins arrive okay
well how nice of chester to conveniently
start barking at the shed when hopper
came over it's almost like he read the
script
hey jesus
light bulbs in the stranger things
universe have great dramatic timing
especially considering the monster
should be long gone by now are they
reacting to hopper is he a hopper gorgon
thanks for coming out teach
we really appreciate it she died a few
years back sorry
his kid geez lady do you go around
knocking down the gutters on people's
roofs too i mean since you seem so good
at eavesdropping good thing there's
always a town gossip around when we need
to get some heavy handed expositioning
and pronoun gaming few things are more
80s than the boyfriend at the window
trope and falcon and grover duffer
continue to mainline that nostalgia my
problem is that it never takes the time
to explore the deeper aspects of the
things it's referencing meaning we spend
all of our time at the surface level
which is really only the tip of the
spielberg you know it's funny your your
voice sounds different
oh my god they killed toby they know
what eleven is capable of right how did
they think holding her at gunpoint was
going to go down also with all the 80s
references in this film not giving
matthew modine a set of keys dangling
from his pocket was a missed opportunity
no which polymers occur naturally
starch and cellulose but those aren't
the only examples of natural polymers
and the question didn't ask for a
specific number how would anyone pass
this [ __ ] test you're an idiot steve
harrington you're a beautiful nancy
wheeler as great as this show is it
definitely has an annoying habit of
characters calling each other by their
full name i got your x-men 134
like will's gonna buy that dustin you're
not bringing out a mint conditioned copy
of too late the heroes and a [ __ ]
thunderstorm get your nerdy head out of
your ass sorry i went dark there horror
show opens up on a dark and rainy night
cliche where's your hair you have cancer
we've got cancer jokes yo we went out to
find will not another problem i think we
should tell your mom yes they should and
how is it possible not one of these kids
tells an adult the thing about stranger
things that has always bugged me the
most is how they handle the 11 situation
early on this feels more like a generic
sitcom plot device than anything that's
actually interesting if i tell my mom
and she tells your mom and your mom oh
man our houses become alcatraz and look
i know it's been a while since i was a
kid but certain things trump a fear of
grounding and i'm pretty sure freaking
out scared speechless girl with blood on
her shirt is making that list
is that real
sorry i've just never seen a kid with a
tattoo before and i have zero knowledge
of personal boundaries so there's that
escher and hawthorne duffer continue to
avoid using their first names in the
credits we however will not abandon our
responsibility to provide names for them
you think i don't know my own son's
breathing yes exactly with the headspace
you appear to be in i'm not sure i'd
take anything you say without an entire
salt line of salt my point is writer is
making a choice here and it's great but
it has consequences for our empathy for
the character
first you test my patience by only using
three eggos and a four slot toaster and
then you eat them without any kind of
butter or syrup and mrs butterworth is
standing right there show doesn't know
how to eggo correctly
hey what's going on um brother sister
footsie okay last mention but it
deserves another sin 11 just told mike
that people were literally going to kill
her and him and he still doesn't mention
it to his mom that's a level of tweening
that i just can't comprehend one episode
later and matthew's hair is still a sin
intense door closing what if he slept
naked dustin is just the best one of the
things ignacio and jarvis duffer got
right about this age is how obsessed
preteen boys are with sex without even
understanding it and teen boys and young
adult men and you know what just add a
sin for all of us no one will be seated
during the 11th seated sequence all the
best stuff's on there joy division bowie
television the smiths wow the smiths
that's some real older brother cred
right there considering the smiths
barely had their first singles out in
the uk in 1983 whoever the british
version of jonathan is might have
vaguely heard about them but i'm
guessing that info hasn't made its way
to hawkins yet and you shouldn't like
things because people tell you you're
supposed to like this very show for
instance radio shack also i guess it's
possible this could be a parking space
but whoever parks there would have to
back out in the middle of an
intersection so regardless of the
probability that's definitely a sin uh
yeah you know uh i gave jonathan all my
money for for the copies for the posters
uh
i needed advance for a show that only
has eight episodes in its first season
you wouldn't think we'd have a lot of
time for the frazzled mom buys a new
phone and begs for an advance on her
paycheck from her boss for three minutes
and yet i need this phone and two weeks
advance and a pack of camels
damn we're only 20 minutes in and there
have been three instances where
cigarettes have come into play i don't
even smoke and i want to pack i know
it's the 80s but can we cool it with the
cools let me step out of the vehicle a
little more pronounced and pause while
glaring for a second so you know i'm a
little more important than these other
guys in suits also the upside of writing
sins is that it has taught me a lot one
of those things is proper hazmat suit
technique which in this case should be
sleeves and pant legs outside gloves and
boots and tape down otherwise
contaminants can easily find their way
inside the downside is that if i'm
having sex i now feel the need to duct
tape the outside of the condom and
that's a downside for everyone involved
his name's yoda he can use the force to
move things with his mind mike just
happens to pick the same power that
eleven will display later i won't tell
her about you i promise considering how
loud mike is speaking my guess is she
already knows or she's deaf if we get a
call from over at benny's i think you
need to get there right away no reason i
figured you should be in just as much
suspense as the audience when it comes
to what's happening at benny's well i
mostly dealt with strangers back then i
called my job stranger things oh look
someone in 1983 somehow had dish network
or directv i wonder if they'll dump it
for netflix in 1987. i'm pretty sure
newt and lemuel duffer had it written
into their contracts that every episode
must include kids on bikes just so we're
sure to get a bit of that amblin
dopamine hit
no and this is definitely when the
screaming starts wait you're telling me
they just keep befriending her and going
along with it after this even after she
turned her powers up to 11.
no look
all i'm saying is maybe i'm not the
[ __ ] all right yeah except you don't
seem to be concerned about where will is
so maybe you are i swear to the
demogorgon we had this exact serving
dish and plate set when i was growing up
part of the reason the show works so
well is because of little details like
this so i'm taking a sin back because i
swear i ate green bean casserole out of
that exact dish for will
[Music]
the one major character need 11 has is
not being discovered in the previous
scene she had even used her powers to
make sure none of the boys said a word
about her now she's just wandering
around the house like none of the
previous 33 minutes of this episode even
happened can't ask of course a question
well not with that attitude you can't
miracle max would like a word with you
what is friend for all it does right
this show isn't exactly nuanced does it
he just wants to get in your pants no he
doesn't yes
seriously barb would be great at tv sets
although if she were really good she
would have found a way to do rhyming
sins with gnats pants romance chants and
second glance tommy and carol have been
having sex since like seventh grade
it'll probably just be like a big orgy
with five people and no monkey waiters
with grapes come on barb you're just
being silly at this point never feel
cursed david harbor's audition for
hellboy makes it into an episode that
seems like a lot of light for a trunk to
be shining out onto his face i mean
unless jules briefcase is in there i'm
calling ford nanigans jonathan's
convenient stroll through the woods is
conveniently close to the convenient
party at steve's where he conveniently
wanders up on them after conveniently
hearing a noise show uses alcohol and
cigarettes to establish a bad boy
persona cliche you are a cliche you do
realize that what the did she hear me
hello nancy am i trapped in the upside
down
i'm really thinking tommy's motion here
is much less chug chug chug and much
more stroke stroke stroke but whatever
tommy h you do you literally
this has happened to me a lot i go out
taking pictures at the place where my
brother went missing hear a scream spy
on teens making out and i am compelled
to take pictures of that instead oh no
no no
oh no no no no
oh no no no no oh no no no no no
i would give every sin back if zelda
rubenstein showed up right now and told
joyce to tell will that she's going to
give him a spanking while he wouldn't
dare play should i stare should i go we
assure you this is a case of the same
song used in a previous flashback that
just happens to be ready to play on
cassette for maximum emotional impact
just in case you've missed the complete
spielberg rip-off built into almost
every scene mansfield and norwood duffer
include direct homages as well
[Music]
considering barb is the conscious of
this show i can't wait to see how she
gets rescued by the end of the season
and gets her i told you so moment this
is gonna be so good oh thank god we know
the fate of barb i was really concerned
that they were gonna wait till much
later in the series and that they would
just show a random shot of her dead body
glad that would never happen ah yes the
horror tradition of cutting between
someone getting chased or brutally
murdered by a monster and a teenage
sexual situation nothing weird or
disturbing about that i want my mummy
also we wouldn't dare play the music but
playing foreigner in a love scene set in
the 80s cliche despite having plenty of
time between the sitting of episodes two
and three oswald and pembroke duffer
have ignored the public outcry to reveal
their first names also in case you were
worried i want to confirm this theme
still slaps i don't know if it's the
cinematographer the dp the gaffer or
steve's parents but it's night time and
somebody needs to be held responsible
for the amount of light entering this
room right now that's a lot of lamps who
has this many lamps you don't need more
labs true are lamp interventions a thing
lamp interventions interlamptions we
just tell our parents we have av club
after school av club av club every
apparently 80's knew that we have a v
club was code for going to the library
to look at baird breast and national
geographic right right you're gonna take
out the demogorgon with a slingshot says
the kid that only brought food what are
you hoping the demogorgon has a peanut
allergy first of all it's a wrist rocket
it is not imagine all the other cool
stuff she could do i guess by all the
other cool stuff you meant specifically
levitate the millennium falcon because
you walk past all the other things lying
around the room to get to the one object
under a blanket in the corner also
nobody puts the millennium falcon in a
corner if you get hungry eat dust and
snacks okay but dustin brought all those
snacks to give the group stamina for
their mission after school mike is a
dick to dustin's snacks michael coming
screaming at your parents when they ask
you to do a simple task it's not cool
kids it's really not cool nancy's
caressing that trapper keeper so hard
the 80s nostalgia will not be able to be
contained any longer it will burst out
like a newborn child running rampant all
over the pop culture landscape for the
next six years and burn the essence of
the 80s into every [ __ ] piece of film
and television that it can wait what was
this in here and why do i have a desire
to buy butterfly stickers damn you 80s
nostalgia damn you to hell you're being
paranoid i mean maybe she is at least
about what's behind the intent of the
stairs but this girl is clearly staring
daggers at nancy so i'd want to know
what the [ __ ] is up with that as well
all she brought to class was her copy of
descent from xanadu either she didn't
show up ready to learn in the show
deprived us of a lecture about the
sexually irresistible jud crane
shouldn't you know writers have this
minor character answering a question
with a question to assuage any doubt
that this high school is filled to the
brim with [ __ ] i guess we're going
to blow the rescues of smithereens the
unnerving coincidence of the cold war's
greatest hits becoming relevant again as
i'm watching this episode in 2022. can i
help you uh yeah we're here for a tour
why would hopper start with this reason
he gives a perfectly logical explanation
in a second about having to check the
facility because it's a nearby location
will could have run off to why not start
there and knock him off as if you're up
to something sneaky right from the
get-go like i said you have to speak to
mr schaefer let me shut off my engine
and remove my hat because this is 1983
code for i'm friendly but i also mean
business
[Music]
devaluing this collectible by repeatedly
smashing it into the ground taking
someone's lazy boy for a spin without
explicit consent what's next eleven can
you eat someone's french fries without
asking there are several sacred things
in this world that you don't ever mess
with one of them happens to be another
man's fries two episodes later and
matthew modine's hair is still a sin
believing this rat's nest of christmas
lights could ever be untangled pixar
didn't happen thanks to this shot i now
know all about ring shank nails okay
maybe not all but i know they exist and
that this is certainly overkill for
mounting some christmas lights i don't
know but they're lying this they're
hiding something cliche underlying a
shadowy government-funded conspiracy
cliche wrapped in a i love the story so
i didn't really want to send it but i
have to cliche i'm no stranger to
exercising the old power stance but is
there a reason to be standing so close
to this equipment as it's being dropped
into place i mean at that distance your
mini modine's gonna need a hard hat
the quietness of this scene juxtaposed
against the violence she experienced at
the lab serves as the perfect expression
of just how upside down a levin's life
has been compared to the relatively
normal lives of everyone else we see her
being mesmerized by the simplicity of
this world in the same way we're
captivated by the supernatural aspects
of hers hats off to the production team
for making me see here and feel this
snooping i don't care what it is it's
disgusting just get off the table he's
not wrong but they all should be equally
disgusted that she has the same shoes on
the table that have most likely graced
the germ-infested realm known as the
lavatory she's not a superhero
she's a weirdo what does that matter the
x-men were weirdos mike would be the
dungeon master at free period superpower
debate sins what are you losers doing
back here probably looking for their
missing friend i love all the stephen
king vibes this show gives off i really
do but i could have done without the
it's a stephen king story about kids so
there has to be belize cliche i think
all of us could have done without that i
brought you a casserole when exactly did
casserole become the go-to you're having
a bad time guess you need one of these
food for once i want to see someone
having the best darn day of their life
and their best friend shows up all like
heard everything was going great for you
there buddy but wait there's more i
brought you a casserole also casserole
you can find the corresponding micro
fish in the reading room i've heard
tales of this mythological microfiche
and its ability to conjure information
long thought to be lost but to this day
there's been little evidence beyond tv
movies and the stories told by wise old
bibliothecaries perhaps one day i'll
journey beyond the stacks of historical
fiction and into the fabled regions of
the third floor at my local library
where sightings have been reported but
until i see it with my own eyes i cannot
stand idly by as this show claims the
existence of the microfiche to be a fact
the librarian why not the librarian i
can see taking issue with the way hopper
conducts his personal affairs but your
specific concern regarding this woman's
vocation makes about as much sense as my
insistence on using the word
bibliothecary
[Music]
this fish is on for so long i'm not sure
why they didn't name the episode gone
microfiching let me throw in that
casserole okay you brought the casserole
to the private lives of pipoli's winona
ryder uncooked what the [ __ ] karen since
november 28th was a monday in 1983
either someone is going to be very late
for an event that happened in 1980 or
someone is being very optimistic about
their plans for 1986. oh man he is like
totally trembling you must really have
something behind steve's being a little
over the top here but jonathan isn't
exactly the innocent those photographs
are creepy and definitely not approved
by the photographys and i hate that
quizno and remington duffer are actually
making me side with the kids beating up
on the weakling did a few good men teach
you nothing
throwing the one guy up against the wall
can be justified as a fight-or-flight
reaction but the snapping of the neck is
very brutal i would dare say too brutal
for the child protagonist that we're
supposed to be rooting for i love subtle
period dudges like this nelson bench
designed in 1946 however i'm completely
taken out of the scene by the fact that
thanks to a resurgence in the popularity
of mid-century modern furniture this bad
boy now costs over fifteen hundred
dollars thank you very much herman
miller no one will be seated as ottoman
new york's winona ryder paints the
alphabet in real time talking running
driving excitement hey phil how can we
show the seriousness of this scene where
the kids are following the cops to the
body i don't know gary maybe we have
them um i don't know he tried their
bikes through a puddle that we'll have a
close-up shot on phil this is exactly
why they pay you all the money genius
it's really well siegfried and tristan
duffer thinking anyone's actually going
to fall for this will's dead fake out
when we all know it was just an excuse
for the beautifully stylized ending of
this episode whoever you found is not my
boy guess i'm removing a sin straight
out of the gate joyce's reaction to her
experience with the christmas lights the
demogorgon coming through the wall and
then moments later hearing about will's
body being found is the perfect balance
of frantic terrified and hopeful when
none is pulling off a top-notch
performance in this series i'm here for
it he was talking with this
talking that feeling when as a viewer
you know the wild rambling is true but
all the characters in the story
rightfully think the wild rambling is
just wild rambling because it sounds
well wild while this does a great job of
putting you in the shoes of the same
character it just doesn't feel good the
bright light over their heads is a
reminder that the house does in fact
have electricity joyce can't afford
cigarettes but she can afford the
expensive light bulb with selective
electric currents that scan the room and
amplify dramatic tension or maybe the
lack of lighting is a tactic to attempt
to hide the chaos glitter in the house
no i'm not blaming the people for the
mess it's the bulb's fault for giving
them that if you don't see it you don't
have to deal with it vibe [ __ ]
stranger things bulb man
okay last mention of the lighting
situation but it's pretty clear from the
light streaming in from the bathroom
window that when joyce was outside she
should have been blinded by whatever
bulb is attempting to mimic the [ __ ]
sun blind i thought we were friends you
know our friends tell each other the
truth kids are so dumb they blame
everyone else for their own inability to
process and manage emotions and let
downs super glad we grow out of that
phase as we age what you did sucks lucas
was right about you not only does mike
survive saying this to a person who can
snap next with their mind but he also
does not immediately apologize when he
finds out that eleven was telling the
truth even though he now knows that it
was him being the [ __ ] all along you
know maybe i've been focused on the lack
of first names for too long now maybe
maybe the names are actually a hidden
secret message just waiting to be found
oh sh
what does it mean you can stop by the
video store on the way back pick out
whatever you want even r-rated yes
because the thing a grieving kid needs
to have is a good old jolt of r-rated
adrenaline i guess i should need another
reminder that we're in the 80s when
parents didn't give a [ __ ] about scaring
their little ones for life by inviting a
boy and his dog into the subconscious
lucas do you copy i'm surprised that he
eventually does copy the antennas on
these old radios fully extended would be
like four feet long so while i'm not
saying that mike and lucas wouldn't have
any reception at these lengths the show
is still definitely overlooking the one
situation where size does matter
i guess some two-way radios will allow
the other person to cut in which totally
eliminates the need for over and out
which is clearly the coolest part of
communicating in this way also why are
these two fully dressed and already back
in bed you mean about his funeral
no not his funeral screw his funeral i'm
surprised to screw his funeral works and
getting lucas to comply with his request
but i'm even more surprised mike didn't
say that he has some new evidence that
will is alive instead of keeping him in
suspense using this muted color palette
at a coroner's office just because the
people are dead doesn't mean your sense
of style has to be he has a birthmark on
his right arm can you show that to me
please you know what this show never
does it never shows us the birthmark on
the will doll if there's no birthmark on
his arm then everyone should be
suspicious of this dopplewill if there
is a birthmark on whippleganger well my
sinful question is simply how how did
the [ __ ] from state know about
will's birthmark was his body scanned by
someone before he popped into the
underbelly of pg horror what the [ __ ] is
the hawkins police badge's symbol anyway
it's like the department had to
compromise with the person who wanted a
dangerous looking weapon and a nature
lover obsessed with dandelions
yelling angrily at a woman who was just
asked to identify the body of her son
when you talk to the cops just
don't mention the beers thinking anyone
cares about the beers in a town with an
ever increasing missing person problem
has got to be the prototypical teenage
boy equivalent of eating an apple
because this scene doesn't move the plot
forward as much as it paints steve as an
[ __ ] i know it sounds crazy i i i
sound crazy you think i don't know that
it is crazy word-for-word dialogue of me
explaining why michael bay's remake of
ambulance is a modern-day masterpiece
makes it into the show i am not gonna
stop looking for him until i find him
and bring him home
i am going to bring him home no offense
mom but choice is not my mom trying to
find a way to bring me back from a dark
dimension in this scene where is a lie i
see we have the ever annoying shout the
absurd truth that no one believes until
they believe you cliche at play here
there is no way we're gonna get the
weirdo in there without anyone noticing
i mean
look at her i know it was the 80s and
gender stereotypes were all the rage but
this need to make 11 look pretty in pink
seems more about cramming in your homage
to et than it is about anyone actually
being concerned with her appearance you
know how when you drive a car at night
with the interior lights on it can with
some of your vision this helmet is
giving me those vibes they're high beams
hugging his cheek bones and lighting up
the entirety of his field of vision what
the [ __ ] use is that it helps us see him
but i highly doubt he can see much
further than a few feet in front of him
unless this was designed for us to see
every one of his pores in which case the
helmet lights are great matthew minion's
hair is finally covered in this scene
good luck in there son miss redshirt
thinks he's going to survive this and
kurtz's life
was running swiftly too
nancy wheeler mr triple muffin doesn't
respond to this interruption with what
the [ __ ] principal pumpkin scruffle it's
hard enough teaching joseph conrad to
these insulin little [ __ ] without you
busting in here like the tater flip and
kool-aid man the school's decision to
keep score at will's memorial assembly
may be the strangest thing in this
episode i'm
no
you're not not listening to the person
you're accusing of not listening while
they are actively listening this show is
set a standard that all lamps in the
kids rooms must be on and i'm suddenly
very upset that this lamp isn't on no
one will be seated as nancy stitches
together a picture with an important
detail that's located on an intact
portion that does not need to be
stitched together at all the show wants
us to believe that when nancy hastily
picked up some of these ripped up
pictures in the previous episode she
managed to get all the pieces needed to
put this one of barb completely back
together and i want to believe that one
of the writers definitely pulled this
out of their upside down also taping the
top of the picture rather than the back
of the picture
but slowly like super slow my yelling
may make it seem like reeling him in is
urgent but just you know really take
your time will was an exceptional
student
and a wonderful friend to all of us i
believe will is a good kid and even an
exceptional student but there's no way
he had time to be friends with the whole
school let alone be a wonderful one look
at these fakers
they probably didn't even know his name
till today faking what these expressions
of boredom every one of these kids was
forced to be at this assembly just like
you so just slow down there with the
judgments boys it's kids who circle the
entire gymnasium to get a better view of
a fight they grow up to cause a
mile-long slowdown on the freeway
because they can't avoid looking at the
accident just [ __ ] go didn't you
listen to the counselor wheeler grief
shows herself in funny ways riders don't
realize the potential of their funny
ways spin-off
[Music]
and one cent for me because perfect
stranger things was there the entire
time
we all want to think that troy pissed
himself out of fear but deep down we're
all pretty sure eleven used some sort of
telekinetic catheter to force p from
this poor kid's bladder and while we all
hate troy i don't believe we'd wish this
on our greatest enemy hey what's going
on here principal coleman says this 15
seconds after the laughing began
30 seconds after troy's death threat
you're dead wheeled in almost a full
minute after the entire gymnasium began
to go silent when any seasoned school
admin would know that this many kids
being quiet is a telltale sign that the
proverbial pudding cup is about to hit
the overhead projector i don't know what
your budget is but over here we we have
copper and bronze selling things to
grieving people your mom um
she said you'd be here stalking he
didn't have a face i need to address the
elephant in this episode he didn't have
a face but he had no face this refusal
to ask the important questions like did
it have eyes and does it have human
grace deprived us all of the painfully
appropriate billy idol b plot we all
wanted and me personally have the
opportunity to say les you son visage
cliche odentalgia ah yes july 15 2016
the day google saw a spike of interest
in tooth pain and double down on ads to
dentistry nationwide suckers whoop the
hair is back she's finding him this is
crazy calm down she just closed her eyes
sure we as the viewers know she's
locating will right now but mike and
dustin do jump to conclusions way too
often and lucas really doesn't get
enough credit for his insistence on
empirical evidence
what is that
seems about 10 years too early but i'm
pretty sure it's the first track off the
upside downward spiral
when joyce tears the wallpaper and sees
will on the other side she doesn't
immediately get the axe and try to break
through the wall i know it can't work
for story reasons but not even trying
till it's obviously too late leaves open
the possibility that it could have
worked it makes this seem very
frustrating to watch i applaud him for
being proactive and attempting to subdue
the flames but dustin is shooting the
front of the radio with the extinguisher
when the back is obviously on fire my
vintage stereo receiver once suffered a
similar fate as the heath kit and while
i chose instead to flee with my life i
found my knowledge of the flame's
location very helpful in my hasty
retreat given the time period there's
most likely asbestos somewhere in that
wall and this type of demolition is a
big no-no stephen king is staring right
into the camera in this scene part of me
loves hopper part of me is angry that he
doesn't drag the out-cold body of the
state trooper into the room so his
shenanigans aren't easily noticed i'd be
so good at covering up crimes wait
hopper's about to find out that this is
some kind of jim henson muppet version
of will and while the surprise isn't
completely lost on me i have to say that
even a casual fan of csi miami would
have been made suspicious by the lack of
hawaii incision and i'm not saying that
i know anything about actual autopsies
but if the shadow we grew behind the
cover-up was more detail-oriented they
could have fooled me for at least a
couple more seconds in my shadowy group
i of course mean uriah and voltaire
duffer also we're all glad that he cuts
into the will doll because it gives us
some closure that all of this isn't in
joyce's head but go with me here how do
we know that stuffing bodies with
stuffing isn't just a normal thing that
happens like does anyone ever double
check that this is abnormal all we want
right now is for hopper to tell joyce
that he checked the body and believes
her but instead we get lonnie previously
on the x-files
being somehow oblivious to the six foot
three 245 pound man sneaking about your
laboratory look i get that hopper knows
some shady shirts going down but to be
honest the consistency of said is
totally unknown to him which makes
walking into this quarantined area
without any sort of safety gear and
extremely questionable move is jim
hopper
chief jim hopper
yeah i've got jim hopped okay the radio
someone to confirm i meant to be here
bluff enabled hopper to disarm the first
dude but i've got no idea how he managed
to get the drop on the second guy who
really should have already had his gun
ready to go drink
i'll calm your nerves
and help you think straight yes please
give me the thing that makes it illegal
for me to drive to help me think
straight even in the 80s this was known
to be dumb advice don't look at me like
that what like how everybody is looking
at me like i'm out of my damn mind
considering the thing she's claiming is
that a demon monster stole her child
while she was communicating with him
through a membrane to a nightmare
dimension hidden in her living room wall
a couple of sideways glances are
probably fair you remember your aunt
darlene no
no
this is not
that well then here's a sim for not
giving us a flashback of that one time
crazy aunt darlene beat up the milkman
mailman and garbage man on the same day
because she thought men in uniform were
challenging her authority how am i
supposed to calculate the level of
joyce's sanity if i don't have an
example of and arlene's peak craziness
well
well
well will five episodes in and matthew
modine's hair is still a sin upside down
what'd she say upside down what
upside down come on kid say it one more
time you might be able to summon the
beetle gorgon this is where will is
the upside
down like the veil of shadows
also something that's always bugged me
is how our favorite nerds manage to nail
what the upside down is based on the
smallest slithers of information they've
gathered so far i mean all they know is
that will is missing somewhere that's
dark strange and sort of familiar they
combine that with eleven saying upside
down and make the leap to extra
dimensional mirror land instead of
assuming will is being hung from his
ankles in his own basement the veil of
shadows is a dimension that is a dark
reflection or echo of our world and to
top it all off this belief is reaffirmed
by a literal work of fiction it is a
place of decay and death as opposed to
our regular dimension where nothing ever
decays or dies also dust narration well
i wish i had hopper's ability to let my
sense of adventure take over my sense of
self-preservation no dusty decay flaked
hallways of an underground lab can stop
this man for where there's no will
they're somehow still away
i guess you can't get a good read of the
situation unless you stimulate at least
four of the five senses despite having
plenty of time between the sinning of
episodes four and five waylon and zaden
duffer have ignored the public outcry to
reveal themselves take that down
it's inappropriate evil dead poster
shaming look nice sweetie complimenting
someone who is going to a funeral on
their choice of clothing this room is
lamp tacular kind of get the ones on the
bed post i mean they're pretty cool but
why did will's room also need one here
and here damn it i bet that globe is
even illuminated
wait should we tell will that jennifer
hayes was crying at his funeral for
anyone who thought sam nudging steve to
check out sharon carter and captain
america civil war was the most
inappropriate funeral scene ever
stranger things would like you to hold
its dry eggo waffle paranoid character
tears up their house looking for
recording devices cliche oh cool and a
random blade works is a lockpick cliche
one more cliche and i get a free you'd
better come take a look at this bumper
sticker bumper sticker what you can tell
someone but they're not gonna believe
you
you know that
your mom would jeez nancy learn to read
the room this is not an appropriate time
for your mom dig also if his goal is to
make sure his mother doesn't go through
any more trauma could i be so bold as to
suggest not risking the life of her last
remaining offspring but what if right
next to her acrobat
there is
a flea now the fleet can also travel
back and forth just like the acrobat
here's where things get really
interesting they do not
what are you doing what does it look
like i'm doing being the worst handyman
ever first of all hanging some drywall
would have helped the hole on the inside
of the home and then the boards can be
put on the outside until you can get
someone out to repair it fully second of
all nailing eight nails in a cluster on
the right and two on the left is all
kinds of tim the tool man idiotic and
gets you two extra synths i told you not
to take these down
they were in the way babe calling any
woman that you aren't in a relationship
with babe do you even understand how a
compass works no one understands how a
compass works dustin no one but god help
me i will keep these lights up until the
day i die my yearly outside christmas
lights mantra somehow makes its way into
this episode i cried for a week
i'm a fan of thumper this kid is alive
during the golden age of disney animated
movies and his favorite character is
from bambi the years 1983 which means
you have movies like robin hood the
jungle book the rescuers peter pan and
the fox and the hound yet you reach back
to a boomer aged movie to grab your
favorite character from get with the
times kid you'll be left back at black
cauldron while we're watching toy story
yes he and my mother love each other at
some point but skip
this is not how you answer a phone i
know technology's changed but as a child
of the 80s i can assure you the correct
procedure is to state this is the hopper
residence my brother is a fart nugget
how may i direct your call how do we
know when we get to the gate oh i think
a portal to another dimension is going
to be pretty obvious dustin would be
zuul at tv sins minority reporting your
child yesterday with the cameron he's
not like that at all yesterday yesterday
episode expects us to believe that only
a day's pass and steve broke jonathan's
camera they found will's body and had a
funeral since then get the [ __ ] out of
here with you yesterday nancy oh i was
just starting to think you're okay
believe it or not i actually have a
limited amount of skips per episode and
if this show isn't careful with the
amount of divorce drama alcoholic cop
drama and teenage drama drama i'm gonna
have no skips left for when we
eventually send euphoria maybe they get
moved
no i don't think it's the gator why why
couldn't it be the gate messing with the
magnets it could be underground a mile
in the sky or the [ __ ] car over here
dustin my dude you're easily the
smartest kid here but you have zero clue
how this gate will present itself admit
it
there's blood i knew it lucas come on i
saw her wiping her nose on the tracks
she was using her powers admitting to
being able to have done this
interrogation hours ago saving enough
time to find the portal in my desire to
send the rest of this episode
okay
should be okay or you could leave the
[ __ ] house right i mean this is the
sort of search you can never be
satisfied as complete is this a
watered-down cerebro these scientists
must have never read an x-pin comic if
you want to infiltrate people's minds
all you need is a big room a bald head
and the desire to sit it's been hit by a
car what car do you know of that has
teeth [ __ ] nancy this straight could
be in the middle of disney world and
penn gillette could be inside tempting
me with a pack of oreo thin mints and a
brad bird signed edition of the
incredibles and i still wouldn't crawl
into the damn thing but nancy just goes
right on in all alone as if her friend's
younger brother and her own best friend
weren't missing and presumed dead
yardley and zane duffer entered the
previous episode with nocturnal me by
echo and the bunnymen knowing full well
how committed we are to the binge and
they had the audacity to not open this
episode with the killing moon
[Music]
jonathan also nancy is now running
around like she doesn't know she's in
the over easy and then if she wants to
get back to the sunny side up she's got
to crawl back through the gooey tree we
all know the rime the one who crawls
through the gooey trees press their luck
and now must flee and if tomorrow you
wish to see crawl your ass back through
that gooey tree also also after running
around in every which direction she
somehow manages to end up at the correct
gooey tree unless there are multiple
gooey trees which would have also been
incredibly convenient oh really because
no girl would ever blow off king steve
okay these stephen king references are
just getting weird at this point also we
wouldn't dare play the music but corey
hart's sunglasses at night was a mega
hit that was released as a single in
1984. therefore it wouldn't be getting
radio airplay near the end of 1983 which
is when the first season of stranger
things takes place
steve will ascend oh so stealthily up to
nancy's window which is all well and
good but if you're trying to be all eye
spy with your late night meetups how
about not leaving your car parked on the
street with the headlights on and the
futuristic singings of one corey heart
blasting out of the radio yeah it was a
drawing of a an adult and a child it
said 11 on it i suppose these two dashes
could be an 11 but you looked at this
for a few seconds and reached this level
of certainty for all you know these
could have been tally marks which would
have made this mean two or it could have
been the letter i twice which would have
made it mean
it was a kid's drawing choice it was
stick figures wasn't will oh yes the old
my kid's a better artist than your kid
defense it's been causing headaches for
all defense attorneys since the stick
figure incident of 1937. i mean what if
this whole time i've been i've been
looking for will i've been chasing after
some other kid hopper chooses to say
this to the mother of the kid he
apparently hasn't actually been looking
for can you just come up here sure but
just in case you're curious that will be
a gun in my pocket you know it can't get
us in here jonathan might be right but
how in the name of the upside down would
he know this jonathan's a dick to
factual reassurance continuing to show
the poster for the thing will not make
it any less of a sin no one had a poster
for the thing in 1983. we're a good 10
years from reassessment and realization
that theatergoers were idiots in the
summer of 1982. yeah
having a pen but no paper you know what
a pinnacle paper gets you a smeared name
on your hand that you won't be able to
figure out three minutes later you'll
wonder if that's a lowercase d or
possibly part of an uppercase b but
you'll never know because you forgot the
paper hopper you forgot the paper now
comes the awkward part where jonathan
has to confess he wet the bed because he
was afraid of getting caught in the
hallway by nancy's parents and then
nancy says she knew it happened three
hours ago and then i have no clue which
one of these characters i'm more
concerned about every time i close my
eyes it's like a dark paradise
oh sorry did i just black out in lana
del rey again i hate it when i do that i
mean oh my heart it breaks every step
that it takes damn it it's
always alone like a bear while most
species of bears do generally hunt alone
they can exist and live within close
proximity to each other meaning nancy
has no way of knowing if there are more
than one of these things and it's odd
that she's not even considering that a
possibility
if it works at least we'll know what's
coming you have zero knowledge of what
you need to do to protect yourself from
the monster but hey at least that's
similar to a shark theory will be
correct good choices are being made here
i made some blueberry pancakes putting
blueberries in pancakes or adding
anything to them for that matter they're
[ __ ] pancakes why are we messing with
perfect foods your mind does not your
mom doesn't knock see nancy that would
have been the perfect time for your mom
jab everyone in indiana being overly
committed to this one design element
mike this isn't your fault yeah it's
lucas's that's sanctimonist well i hope
so no way i'm not shaking his hand like
i really hope so all three of you were
being a bunch of little [ __ ] dustin
would be the dictator of [ __ ] at tv
sins today is a very special day you're
finally getting a haircut because today
we make history omg he's getting a
haircut today we make contact he's not
getting a haircut karen said she made
blueberry pancakes i made some blueberry
pancakes yeah i see no blueberries here
or here i see something that looks like
blueberries here but all the evidence
suggests that she made pancakes and put
blueberries on top of them in all the
ways that matter these are not blueberry
pancakes and once again quit [ __ ]
with pancakes okay
i'll shake i'm really more concerned
about why lucas wasn't immediately
rushed to the hospital dude could have a
concussion or worse after being flung by
11. i know we didn't have will smith
movies telling us the importance of
concussion protocol back in 1983 but
still do you seriously want to fight the
demogorgon with your wrist rocket i took
r2d2 going to fight darth vader are you
seriously going to act like that
wouldn't be the coolest thing ever q
automatic door opening then rolls in a
battle warren r2d2 has just taken out a
whole battalion no that's too many a
platoon of stormtroopers darth vader
looks down and says i sense no fear in
you and deploys his iconic red
lightsaber suddenly seven green
lightsabers emerge from r2d2's dome and
expand like helicopter blades rocket
boosters emerging from the little robo
legs as they launch head first at darth
vader in a spinning green glowing fury
i'm just saying mike needs to get out of
here with his weak sauce putting your
christmas tree up before thanksgiving
you know you have to pay for those
character had a perfect opportunity to
use lego myego in conversation and chose
not to
ah sudden rachel from pet cemetery but
the pet cemetery and not the less
pet cemetery i told you you're wasting
your time no you didn't you gave this
cryptic answer but if you want terry to
tell you anything you're about five
years too late and while becky is the
main offender joyce and hopper didn't
ask any follow-up questions why is
everyone in the scene wasting their own
time this show early on has really
undervalued the character of lucas so
seeing him gear up for a one-man mission
to get his friend back is giving me all
of the feels but also getting rambowed
up in a movie or tv show either made in
the 80s or set in the 80s cliche they'd
pay
a couple hundred bucks to people like my
sister
gave him drugs psychedelics lsd mostly
and then they'd strip her naked and put
her in these isolation tanks my awkward
explanation of the plot of altered
states to my mother somehow makes its
way into this episode this is a cool but
unnecessary flashback montage designed
to explain to us everything we've
already put together about 11's past and
since no one in the room has first-hand
knowledge of what happened at the lab
this awkwardly becomes a flashback of
the viewer's experience and i don't like
the creative license they're taking with
my perspective you're gonna stephen king
the show doesn't care so much whether or
not joyce and hopper have as much as it
wants you to know that the writers did
the handle of this hammer is just
hanging off the edge waiting for someone
to brush by and end up with a broken toe
i feel like we need more backstory on
this guy he just isn't putting in the
effort anymore look at the signage the
two racks on the right are guns sure but
the one on the left is mostly ammo and
racka cooney last week i was shopping
for a new top i thought steve might like
wasting time and money on clothes you
think will make a high school boy happy
you want to make a high school boy happy
show up to where he's currently at
that's it steve and the rest of the high
school cliches were able to get away
with spray painting the front of the
movie theater in the middle of the day
and they hung around afterward to face
even more property even if i let go of
the fact that they don't even appear to
have a ladder this scene has more
contrived vandalism than the tate modern
also nancy conveniently pisses off steve
on a week that all the right moves is
playing at the local theater what would
he have done if it was the next week
when national lampoon's movie madness
replaced it try to use a nancy the [ __ ]
configuration with that title he
assaulted a police officer he is raising
up not realizing someone is behind you
and clipping their nose with your
shoulder really assault i think the
gasoline bullets and bear traps and
jonathan's trunks should be more
concerning but you do you hawkins police
force eating untoasted eggo waffles
toothless some would say why did they
drop their bikes and run but this was
the correct choice look at that terrain
they never get up to speed fast enough
to get away and there are way too many
hazards to navigate the sin here is the
absurd convenience of bulk and skull
showing up out of nowhere to trigger the
conflict that results in eleven also
showing up out of nowhere to save dustin
and mike get up get off me resorting to
murder because you got your ego hurt on
the playground our friend has
superpowers and she squeezed your tiny
bladder with her mom okay show i called
you out for the sheer cruelty of that
scene in episode four but you just owned
it
maybe not deus el machina yeah andre you
better run i get dustin's happy isn't
being held at knifepoint anymore but is
he overlooking the fact that eleven just
broke that kid's arm couldn't she have
just made the knife fly away or
something despite all the security
measures we know this place has lucas is
not spotted joe thinks the government in
the 80s was combating conspiracy
theories by letting the public draw
conspiracy conclusions opening the
episode with mike cleaning 11's face
like my mom after i've just conquered a
double fudge banana split with
marshmallows and whipped cream but this
touching gesture of face touching was
probably not necessary since there's a
mirror
snog blocking also writing in your own
skip doesn't excuse the fact that a skip
was needed
thing the stranger things kids thought
when they saw us getting ready to send
the show somehow makes its way into this
episode
the kids resolve all their issues and
get the band back together in the first
five minutes because they've realized
they're stronger as a team and share a
bond forged in the crucible that is
grade school but also it's the
penultimate episode and they need to set
up the finale if you're already inside
the police station this seems a bit
redundant there's something you need to
see you'd better come take a look at
this cliche what happened to her here
being more concerned about eleven's hair
than matthew modine's wasting time
building a model to describe a fenced in
plot of land next to a road with a
building on it and this is the lab right
here lucas that's a can circling
circling
circling
still circling
you risked your life
and nancy's to be fair going after the
creature was nancy's idea in the first
place jonathan is a high school kid
meaning he just happens to do less
thinking with his top brain and more
thinking with the brain in his upside
down he probably cares about his brother
and stuff too yeah yeah i'm sure it's
more than that boner thing what is your
name deputy asking for the name of a
person wearing a name tag it looks less
likely these agents are collecting
evidence and more likely they're
planning a sleepover the events of this
season are supposed to have taken place
in 1983 but great american ghost stories
by hans holzer wasn't published until
1990 and the dinosaurs went extinct
about 65 million years ago i'm
definitely sending this ridiculous
ladder placement i get they had to get
the stuff on the other side cleaned up
as well but now they're at a point where
the ladder needs to be moved at least to
the middle of the [ __ ] and wheeler how's
steve gonna get any elbow grease into
his cleaning routine from this angle we
should be out there looking for him
honey we have to trust them okay
stranger things does a pretty great job
of having all the 80s goodness mixed in
with some really interesting character
work so why did ted wheeler have to be a
walking believes the government is
always there to help you idiot father
cliche later harrison sho thinks it's
going to get away with us not pointing
out that dustin is pointing at the
person of color in this scene while
pointing out the person of color in
another scene and this is now a
spider-man scene
i never noticed how closely this part of
the score resembled john carpenter and
now the scene is giving off series
halloween three vibes i don't know
whether to remove a sin for the
carpenter-ness of it all or addison
because well you know halloween three so
i'll add five because i'm me hopper
subdues these three intimidatingly
well-dressed agents very quickly and
entirely off-screen so the sin is for
all style and no substance is that my
dress everyone in this show is way too
concerned about eleven's hairstyle and
what she's wearing mike claims to be
explaining the upside down but this
drawing looks more like a person
standing on the horizon next to a gopher
hole i can find them
in the bath show proves the vague posts
were not an original idea formed in the
days of social media and were actually
preceded by vague comments like this
anything about sensory deprivation tanks
specifically how to build one mr clark
appears to have the physical
characteristics of a science teacher but
the show thinks he's a duckduckgo and
for those of you have no idea what i
just said it's the same thing as a
google why are you keeping this
curiosity door locked i'm more curious
as to why dustin or any student has mr
clark's home phone number even for the
80s that's [ __ ] weird you sold that
kiddie pool we bought for apples in
admitting to bobbing for apples
admitting to bobbing for anything really
using de-icing salt instead of epsom
salt this show is addictive 11's skin
now that we're almost to the end of the
season it appears all characters have
acquired enough xp to activate the squad
boost on all talents enabling everyone
to complete their tasks in record time
just like the saying goes teamwork makes
the nightmare stop hey wait
i'm not gonna snow next week is it worst
case no school i feel like that was
missing something cindy run that back
and hit him with the good stuff hey wait
i'm not gonna snow next week is it worst
case no school
perfect why was it necessary to set this
up in the middle of the gymnasium even
if they had to come to school for
equipment and supplies why the very
middle of the gym and not at least a
little closer to your water source black
voids with wet floors i assume ernest
and hansel duffer killed off barb to
raise the stakes but we weren't watching
the show for stakes we were watching it
for the 80s nostalgia and the triumphant
return of barb i demand justice
it's okay i realize you just witnessed
something horrifying that will probably
haunt you for the rest of your life and
you'll never get a good night's sleep
again but i really need you to
concentrate on my son nancy will be able
to make new friends hey so bobby what do
you think as far as making the castle
buyer's ford look creepy and the upside
down well i just have one question for
you hank have you ever wondered what it
would look like if swamp thing burped
the worm all over the place burped the
worm bobby you know sprayed the pajama
glue circumjaculated the globe spilled
his brogurt sundae squeeze the okay
bobby i get it just order the mayonnaise
and never speak to me again i guess
because we're in the last few minutes of
the show jonathan is suddenly capable of
sneaking in and out of the police
station unnoticed after that tense
episode i'm glad i can take a break from
this show
never mind guess i'm clearing my
schedule for the next hour starting your
episode on a star field just to make me
jealous of places with little to no
light pollution i want to see the
universe civilization stop progressing
already show keeps matthew modine
completely shrouded in darkness for the
first 30 seconds making us wait a full
half minute to sin his hair its behavior
is predictable
like
all
animals it eats i mean sure but not all
animals eat children and even more
importantly not all animals live in a
parallel mirror dimension so your
predictions can go suck a slug here's
what's gonna happen character in
captivity tells their captors exactly
what's going to happen before exactly
the thing they said would happen happens
exactly the way they said it would
happen cliche you let me enjoy spires go
you're gonna give us anything we need
and we're gonna find her son
and then we're gonna forget
that any of this ever happened this is
the dumbest deal in the history of
bartering and there's no way the modine
mafia would agree to it honest hopper
expect to convince joyce to not expose
the bastards that faked the death of her
son how does he explain to the people of
discount haddenfield that will byers has
returned from the dead there's bluffing
then there's bluffing when you haven't
seen your cards then there's bluffing
when you haven't seen your cards and
you've never played poker before and
then there's this gun loading hammering
more gun loading trap setting even more
gun loading home improvement also
shooting a close-up of how many bullets
your gun holds when you don't intend on
counting to six later also also thinking
you can home alone a monster from the
underworld
you gotta give me your word
on those other three kids those boys
you're gonna leave them alone
and i'll tell you somehow jaded and
pissed at the world sheriff hopper
believes that the shady government
people conducting experiments on stolen
children are also people likely to be
worried about keeping promises also if
hopper knows how badly brenner wants a
levin back why didn't he leverage him
for more help than just two hazard suits
and a will went that away the atmosphere
is toxic
my son's in there joyce would be an 11
out of 10 at tv sins it's trolls
thinking trolls would choose to hunt in
playgrounds for food instead of the
youtube comments section or whatever the
80s equivalent would have been you okay
i mean i'm wondering through a gui
hellscape looking for my son who may or
may not be dead from toxic exposure
after being kidnapped by the demon
offspring of a venus flytrap and a very
angry horse but other than that i'm just
swell you i get that the floating
particles add some distinguishing
eeriness to the upside down but where is
it coming from and why is it constant
does the sky have dandruff do all the
creatures just have severe eczema is it
always winter and never christmas did
you hear that it's just the wind just
the wind tornadoes are just the wind man
wind can mess you up do you even wizard
of oz bro nancy
getting knocked blocked
get out she points the loaded gun at him
and [ __ ] it that's dumb nancy's dumb or
the show is dumb or the show is dumb for
making nancy so dumb what's it doing
asking a question to a room full of
people who have exactly the same
information that you do excessive and
inexcusable egg examination is
excretable yet exhaustingly expected
everything in the upside down will
remind hopper of his child because
somehow it knows this is the season
finale and that the writers forgot to
finish telling us his backstory for
pitysign not to ask her any more
questions she said i must have asked her
a thousand already i suppose i had to
but how are you gonna find things have a
few nice questions ignoring punctuation
i mean if i delivered sins like this
wouldn't it be incredibly distracting
and difficult to follow because commas
man how do they work and actually we
know how they work and allow pauses so
we can breathe in or give our brain some
time to catch up and process what's
being said someday somehow we're
supposed to believe that hopper reads
entire books to his child this way and
survives this
finally someone's acting reasonable and
getting the ever loving hell out of
hawkins the second the death creature
from another world shows up wish more of
these and he's about to go back in isn't
he the demogorgon will now play older
brother and pin jonathan to the ground
and hang slobber over him for a bit
before doing anything because that's
just basic predatory instinct more like
the demo borgin am i right what is the
number of the daytime
[Music]
[Music]
showing off your bat spinning skills
instead of immediately killing the
flower-faced goo demon so the plan here
is to set the beast on fire for a few
seconds and then immediately put it out
like that you want to save the house but
shouldn't you toast that sucker for a
little longer see marshmallows survive
longer than this
[Music]
i has to be dead
yes the interdimensional being that can
inexplicably travel between your world
and its own is definitely dead don't you
dare let the lack of a body make you
think otherwise and of course hopper and
joyce arrive at the exact same hallway
where the kids just had the demogorgon
barbecue did they bring the graham
crackers and the chocolate bars for the
s'mores
dust is just the best
she can make you whatever you like
that ghost
well
yeah it goes but real food too shut your
mouth keep that eggo shade out of my 80s
nostalgia thank you mike friends don't
lie but we do skip i know that just
following orders excuse doesn't mean
these are good people but i'm not
convinced they all deserve to have their
insides liquefied and that we should
still be expected to root for discount
dozen i mean she's responsible for more
recorded deaths than the demogorgon at
this point right
11
11 can you hear me holding a barely
conscious child like this so that their
neck is supporting their entire body
what
what
what attempting to clarify your
statement by saying the exact same thing
wait where the [ __ ] did brenner go he
was literally holding his most prized
experiment did he seriously run for the
hills without taking her with him wait
he's still [ __ ] there so he saw the
demogorgon burst in dropped his weapon
of mass destruction got up and walked
directly towards the damn thing as if
he's meeting his day for the snowball
pulling this thing out seems like a
super risky move right they know the
environment's toxic so what if this is
acting as some sort of disgusting life
support system no one's suggesting you
leave him here but let's take a minute
to assess our options before
accidentally pulling his insides to the
outside
is it dead
asking a question to a room of people
who have exactly the same information
that you do also the demi lovato gorgons
haven't received nearly enough credit
for their impeccable sense of dramatic
timing
for a creature that was quickly pouncing
all the bad guys earlier the demogorgon
sure does like to showboat around these
kids huh fortunately i do not suffer
from photosensitive epilepsy but i
imagine this is a thoroughly unpleasant
experience for anyone that does if i
wanted to be flash this much i'd go to
mardi gras no more until the show
becomes a surprise hit then maybe we'll
need something for another season or two
but nothing that would age our actors
out of their parts for sure i mean
barring some sort of worldwide pandemic
a pandemic this periodic table includes
a whole host of elements that hadn't
even been discovered in the 80s
including tennessee which wasn't
discovered until 2010 and [ __ ] you and
your fan fiction if you're going to come
at me saying the upside down is actually
a time portal to the future because if
[ __ ] isn't 29 30 now go
wait maybe the upside down is a time
portal because it clearly teleports
hopper 30 years into the future here
since he's counting out a 30 compression
cpr which wasn't even a thing until like
10 years ago before that it was like
five compressions or so between breaths
and even in hopper's flashback they're
screwing up the cpr because they clearly
show the ekg flat line later meaning she
already had a rhythm and cpr would be
counterproductive i made you a new
mixtape but didn't put a case on it yes
we know who the real monster is now
jonathan
this isn't causing will to scream in
agony after having his rib cage caved in
by hopper
this is how 12 year olds talk about a
violent movie they saw it would not be
how they talk about real life trauma
they experienced so maybe back it down a
notch with the how cool was it when all
the heads exploded reported
sorry about the son of a [ __ ]
even back in the 80s the fireball spell
required the creature being attacked to
rolodice to see if they can dodge it so
mike should have rolled first instead of
letting will go straight for the damage
just because he's had a near-death
experience doesn't mean you go easy on
him dude the campaign was way too short
yeah it was 10 hours but it doesn't make
any sense it makes sense oh no ah yes
the meaning of true fandom to criticize
the thing you love for being too short
too long over-explaining
under-explaining or just not exactly how
you would have written it but clearly
this is anachronistic considering
cinemasins didn't envision a picking
until 2012. can i open it
yeah sure no older brother has ever been
okay with her younger sibling opening a
christmas present from the girl they
have a crush on this is quite likely the
single most unbelievable thing in the
entire show you just had to put up some
news articles didn't you now i have to
read them so explain to me exactly what
you mean by experimentations in perusal
of mind control perusal did you mean
pursuit and sure this could have been a
typo but over here you've clearly got
the same paragraph twice these small
town newspaper editors are lazier than
the props department of a netflix show
you okay
yeah i'm okay i could only assume that
will doesn't immediately tell his family
about his visions or the upslog down he
just coughed up for fear of being
sidelined for all of season two as well
we'll tell you about the game oh yeah
i threw a fire about him and
that's how you start that story not only
is that the big finish but your mom has
no context for who him even is or why a
fireball was needed that's terrible
storytelling will she get some tips from
matt and ross duffer
[Laughter]
matt and ross those may be the dumbest
names we've come up with so far
it's been 84 years
[Music]
time of the night we turn on the black
light let the dungeons and the dragons
begin
boom
boom
here comes
like michael myers i shot him six times
well this is awkward
attention faculty and students
are students two students have just been
expelled for fornicating inside a mufasa
want anything to drink we have oj skim
milk soda o.j purple stuff sun july what
is this place
nancy
what you want to know who fred kruger
was
he was a filthy child murderer who
killed at least 20 kids in the
neighborhood
no
please
please don't say that
i know i've been selfish but i can do
better i can change oh steve i'll have
what she's having if you get hungry eat
dust and snacks okay michael the
meatloaf i heard they make space weapons
in their space weapons an industrial
laser
which emits an extraordinary light not
to be found in nature no matter what
you got
i don't work with o'bannon i say abandon
i meant
drop you
well it all seemed a bit over the top to
me considering
considering what never like him i never
trust her here for all i know he had me
set up and had my friend angel fernandez
killed okay just when you talk to the
cops just tell them i hate them listen
to the day you're around the corner
right here on first avenue mr charlie's
is the name of the place it's the name
of the guy behind the counter and tell
him mr charlie sent you and he'll sell
you cigarettes what's your name again
the name's bond
james bond you're never going to catch
me
you're wasting your time forget about it
don't do something else
see your next meal hey kid would you
please leave without a fuss right now
tommy how's it peeping
tommy
that's a painting tell me again
upstairs are downstairs upstairs there
were horses and a man on fire and i
killed a guy with a trident it was a
kid's drawing choice it was stick
figures
it wasn't will
booyah
meaning it's a predator right there's no
stopping what can't be stopped
no killing what can't be killed why is
he wearing handcuffs you two suck at
peddling meth what happened to her hair
weak follicles leroy i understand how
upsetting this is all i care about is
are you happy with your hair
hey what's your problem man
even smiling makes my face ache
you took my boy away from me give me
back my son freddie piehole como seyama
gayley clarkson you're just a junkie
small town cop who had a really bad week
took one too many pills this time but
once you get locked into a serious drug
collection
the tendency is to push it as far as you
can
look everything that's happened here and
everything is gonna happen they don't
talk about
you want well back
you didn't see anything
i still think we should stick to the
chief's plan oh hell let's just do it we
always do hijacks and nuclear weapons
and hold the world hostage
i don't feel so good